Heath is with us in Jacksonville Florida
hi how are you I'm nervous how are you
doing no troubles what's up I'm worried
that this my fiancee is lying about
payments and this not nursing the
problem that I'm running into is that
she makes she's a financial manager
making about 70,000 a year and I'm
making 20 and we bought a car recently
before I started getting serious into
your book and we've made three payments
and all three payments there's been
issues with because it was the
understanding that she would make the
payments her car that's not nursing I
just had to like cosign for a makes more
money than you and you have cosign for
women why did you have to co-sign for if
she makes three times what you make
because she had a chapter 7 bankruptcy
three years ago mm-hmm and it apparently
dropped her credit down to nothing yeah
that's what a chapter 11 yeah exactly
destroyed her credit okay right she
didn't have it she got bad ground okay
so how expensive is this part right it's
gone up to like fit for T okay how am i
how expensive was this car 20 okay and
when are you got scheduled to be married
we want to get married in June okay and
so have you sat down and said okay
you've had three payments we row for
three on the payments which means as a
financial manager you're not very good
at it and what's one over you broke what
because the money's in the bank she's
made the payments I've seen the payment
like for example this last payment I
visualize I've seen her physically make
the payments three times and I saw it on
the regional acceptance website
she made it like a week ago yesterday it
wasn't on their website anymore I don't
understand
that doesn't make some yeah it doesn't
make any sense she's making a pattern or
absolutely making a payment or if the
regional acceptance is being strange for
some reason I don't know I don't either
but I would want to get to the bottom of
this because let me just tell you dude
when someone will lie about anything
they'll lie about anything and so if
she's lying about this this is time to
tap the brakes on getting married
because somebody that'll lie about that
lie about anything wait and so integrity
is a deal-breaker in an engagement you
know we need to get to the bottom you
know how to get around how to get about
to find out I think you just go listen
I'm really really really really not okay
with the way this is going right now and
we're gonna have to get to the bottom of
this I've got to understand how in the
world I can see a payment going in and
then it is turn around and removed that
does not make any sense and I'm not
going to just accept that oh that's that
they screwed it up I really have got to
understand this you've got to show it to
me I'm not okay with this situation
this is a major problem in our
relationship are you calling me a liar
not yet but I've got to know that before
I can move forward and talk to her about
it but not I have an act for I did ask
for a bank statement because you've got
two different banks and so let me tell
you let me just tell you listening to
you talk there's other stuff that's gone
on where she's jacked around and not
told the truth and told a little white
lies and that's why you're fishing so
deep in this pond am I missing something
there no you got a problem dude you got
a problem the two of you need to be
sitting in front of a marriage counselor
for pre-marriage counseling and get to
the bottom of this and you bought a car
with this woman
oh my lord you got a problem
yeah cuz yeah you you you know stuff
you're not telling me right now that's
what that's what's happening I can feel
it so I'm not gonna digging further the
same in my deal but if you were my son I
would tell you what I just told you and
that's get in front of a good pastor get
in front of a good marriage counselor
and start doing some in-depth
pre-marriage counseling and drag all of
these issues out on the table and let's
really you know the times that she
didn't tell the truth the other times
there was a quote white lie unquote
these are deal-breakers this has to be
solved because you're gonna spend the
rest of your life questioning everything
the woman says if you don't trust her
about anything when she goes on vacation
when she goes on a business trip when
she's when you're out on a business trip
and she's home when she's at the
groceries not everything is in question
when everything's in question and that's
just life is too short so you've got to
get to the bottom of this and feel good
about her character to move forward in
the relationship that's just man to man
talk and that has nothing to with
finances as far as the finances go
if this thing bottoms out you're gonna
be forcing the sale of a car here I hope
your name is on the ownership of the car
not just co-signed it and I hope you
didn't get messed over to that degree
but um yeah yeah you got a mess you got
a mess and you need to dig into it
before you put a ring on her finger
that's gonna this is an issue thanks for
the call